In 1961, the SCP Foundation discovered a town
that was completely devoid of all life.
Not long before their arrival, Darrington,
North Carolina, had been a community with
high aspirations.
A deeply religious township of devout Christians,
many of whom were seeking greater prosperity
from their lives.
But now, their home was a ghost town, with
no sign of any prior Darrington resident to
be found.
Where the hell had they all gone?
It hardly seemed likely that the population
of an entire town would all simultaneously
decide to up sticks and leave to pastures
new.
But then again, maybe the citizens of Darrington
hadn’t left at all.
Perhaps they weren’t even really still human,
and had taken up residence somewhere much
darker…
like underground?
This is the story of one of the earliest known
instances of a phenomena now known under the
designation of SCP-3089, or to use its alternative
name: That Old Time Religion.
When the SCP Foundation arrived in a desolate
Darrington to find the townsfolk had all vanished,
they immediately began an investigation into
the exact ‘how’s and ‘why’s, the answers
to what exactly had happened here.
After all, while not a huge place, Darrington
was home to nearly a thousand residents, and
that many people don’t just disappear.
If they even had disappeared and weren’t
just… dormant.
But what the Foundation uncovered was a gruesome
discovery, that led to them not only demolishing
the entire North Carolinian town, but purchasing
all the land around it to keep the area under
permanent observation.
Prior to demolition, however, the Ministry
of Sevenfold Blessing had been one of the
oldest buildings in Darrington, much like
most town churches.
And it was while searching the offices of
this church that Foundation clean-up crews
discovered their first piece of evidence,
the initial clue about what had happened to
this deserted town.
They recovered a series of cassette tapes,
each with a recording of sermons that had
been given within the Ministry of Sevenfold
Blessing.
These were all delivered by one Pastor Bartholomew
Jenner, the first having been recorded on
August 17th of 1959, two years earlier.
“My friends, I want to talk to you about
the Bible offers, tonight,” Pastor Jenner
began in the first of these recordings.
“I want to talk to you about what you are
owed.
I want to talk to you about…
I want to talk to those of you who are struggling,
right now.
To those of you who have hardship and pain.
Maybe you’ve heard that the Bible only nourishes
the spirit; that God provides only for our
immortal souls.
Well, my friends, I am here to tell you that
this is simply not true.”
Pastor Bartholomew Jenner seemed to be focused
on the discussion of very real, relatable
problems.
After all, what person hasn’t felt unsatisfied
with their life at one point or another?
And this was apparently no different for the
people of Darrington.
“Many of you can think of places in your
lives where you have not yet risen.
Where you are not yet victorious.
Marriage.
Finances.
Health.
But do not fret, my friends.
God wants you to rise.
He has cleared the path for you.
It is one littered with His earthly treasures;
to claim them, you need only to shed your
old selves and be reborn.”
The pastor was merely using the shared faith
of the township to help reaffirm that their
struggles were not the be all and end all
of their lives.
Or at least, that’s how it first appeared.
But the religious practices taking place in
this first recording would soon take a bizarre
turn, making it clear there was something
far more sinister, even cult-like, going on
in the Ministry of Sevenfold Blessing.
“Now, if you would…
some of the ladies from the mayor's office
were kind enough to collect these cicada shells.
Pass them along.
Each of you take one – yes, the children
too.
Be careful.
Very careful.
They are fragile.
Each of you, take one, and hold it in your
left hand.
Yes.
The left hand, not the right.
Your left.”
The shells of dead cicadas hardly seemed like
common fare for a sermon like this.
Although, as the recording continued, it was
easy to understand that Pastor Jenner intended
these discarded insect carapaces to be something
of a metaphor, even if they were pretty gross
– especially to some of the younger members
of his congregation.
He explained to the Darrington residents that
these cicada shells were meant to be symbolic
of whatever hardship the citizens were currently
struggling with in their lives; whether it
was work, a marriage, or an ill family member.
Then came the next part of this unorthodox
practice; the pastor instructed everyone in
the congregation to picture themselves holding
their biggest problem in their left hand…
“Now, I want you to squeeze your left hand.
Squeeze it into a fist.
Feel that problem cracking; like old, dried
out paper.
Feel it crumble to dust,” Jenner told them,
and the residents of Darrington did so, crushing
their cicada shells until there was nothing
left.
“Everyone, open your eyes.
Don't you feel better?
Stronger?
This is what is offered.
Our hardships are like the shell; we shall
cast them aside even as they crumble.
God has cleared a path.”
Needless to say, the Foundation agents that
recovered the tapes of Pastor Jenner’s odd
sermons weren’t entirely sure what to make
of them.
And as unusual as they were, the recordings
did little to indicate where the townspeople
of Darrington, North Carolina, had disappeared
to.
But as they listened further, what they found
was even more unsettling than an entire congregation
of people crushing cicada shells.
In the second recording, dated December 19th
of 1959, Pastor Jenner was once again presiding
over his congregation.
He had just finished quoting a passage from
Matthew, chapter twenty-five, verse thirty,
which related to a Biblical tale known as
the Parable of the Talents.
In this story, a master puts his servants
in charge of a differently sized portion of
his wealth while he is away, then judges them
based on whether or not his servants make
a profit using his money.
The third servant, who had received the least
talents – meaning an amount of money – was
punished for burying his share in the ground;
“cast into the outer darkness” to face
“weeping and gnashing of teeth.”
It was after making mention of this unprofitable
servant that Pastor Jenner went on to address
even more of the bizarre, almost ritualistic,
practices he had been introducing to his sermons.
“Now, some of you have expressed concerns
over the new sacraments.
A few have even called them sacrilege.
And yet, have we not prospered?
Have these same nay-sayers, these same ‘Doubting
Thomases’ not profited from our good works?”
the pastor declared.
“I have shown you how to heal the sick with
the Lord’s Prayer and the blood of an unbaptized
child.
I have shown you how to see your future in
the steaming entrails of a quivering crow.
I have shown you the path to glory.
But I cannot make you follow this path.
I can only show it to you; it is you and you
alone who must follow it – who must rise
and shed your old self.”
Shed your old self.
The words immediately called to mind the image
of the cicadas, insects that discard their
outer carapaces and emerge anew.
Bugs that also burrow into the ground and
wait, lying dormant under the earth for years
at a time.
All before they emerge, rising up again…
so they can spread.
It was becoming clear that Pastor Jenner was
certainly deviating further and further from
the church’s normal religious practices.
His bold and blatant descriptions of what
sounded like ritualistic sacrifices were shocking
enough to hear; speaking of using blood and
entrails to bring the town the prosperity
it sought.
But if that wasn’t bad enough, the worst
was still yet to come… contained within
the third and final recording.
Unlike the previous cassettes, most of the
sermon from June 7th 1960 was almost completely
unintelligible.
And without any visual evidence to go with
it, it was hard for the Foundation to make
out exactly what was going on.
It began with another quote from Matthew,
this time chapter twenty-eight, verse six;
which made mention of the resurrection of
Jesus, that he had risen, and that people
should come and see where the Lord lay.
“Not a metaphor, my friends,” Pastor Jenner
explained, before urging his congregation
to join in some kind of formation.
“Step forward.
Mothers behind their daughters, fathers behind
their sons.
Turn to face the…”
The recording became unintelligible again
after that point, with only a few more words
being audible.
The pastor seemed to have gathered the townsfolk
of Darrington, presumably for some new form
of ritual.
He encouraged the town’s children to close
their eyes and pray, before reminding the
congregation that God sacrificed the life
of his only son, Jesus.
Frighteningly, it appeared that Pastor Jenner
was implying the adults of Darrington should
do the same.
One of the next fragments of his sermon that
could be deciphered declared:
“…lamb is slaughtered to feed the lion.
The Son is slaughtered to feed…”
Between more and more noise interfering with
the recording, Pastor Jenner could be heard
saying:
“The pact is complete.
This world shall be our paradise.”
Before encouraging his congregation – or
those who were left – to dig deep and wait.
Then came perhaps the most horrific part of
the tape.
The remainder of the recording lasted thirty
minutes, comprised of pure static.
Or, the Foundation agents listening to it
assumed, at first, that it was just interference.
But further audio analysis seemed to suggest
that the long, continuous mass of hissing
wasn’t static at all; it was the chittering
sound of insects…
like the noise made by cicadas.
For a time, the incident at Darrington left
the Foundation baffled.
There seemed to be no clear answer as to what
had happened.
Not one of the town’s residents was anywhere
to be found, and on top of that, there were
no bodies.
No remains of any kind to speak of; if they
were dead, there would at least be some kind
of trace.
And then there were all the questions raised
by Pastor Bartholomew Jenner’s strange sermons;
why did he seem so focused on enacting rituals?
Did any of his methods really benefit the
town?
And why did he place so much emphasis on…
cicadas, of all things?
Answers were few and far between, although
almost six decades after the Foundation discovered
the desolate town of Darrington, a new development
would come to light…
To be more accurate, it was fifty-six years
later.
On the 11th January 2017, a Foundation agent
named Daniel Mitchell was patrolling the area
that had formerly been Darrington, North Carolina
– before the Foundation had demolished all
traces of the town.
By this point, the SCP Foundation had long
thought that they had figured out exactly
what SCP-3089 was; they had even encountered
it emerging in a number of different forms
in both 2007 and 2015.
However, it was what Daniel Mitchell happened
across during the routine monthly patrol that
revealed the horrifying truth.
At the outskirts of the area where the town
had once been, a series of sinkholes had opened
up, at some point between the previous monthly
check and this one in early 2017.
And if you think that these sinkholes caused
a disturbance in the earth and uncovered all
the bodies of the former residents or Darrington,
you’d be wrong.
It was far, far stranger…
The Foundation conducted a full-scale examination
of the sinkholes around the demolished North
Carolinian town.
And these weren’t just a few patches of
loose ground that had sunk through.
The geological survey the Foundation carried
out quickly revealed that these sinkholes
led to an extensive network of tunnels deep
underground.
They extended several hundred kilometers outwards,
practically covering the entire underside
of where Darrington had been.
The tunnels seemed far too big than any other
created by any natural means, but the entire
network also appeared too rudimentary, too
imperfect to have been carved using any modern
excavation technology like a large drill.
Plus, if equipment like that had been on site,
the Foundation would have noticed, as they
kept the area monitored.
It was almost like something had been burrowing
through the ground, only to eventually crawl
back up to the surface, resulting in the sinkholes.
What’s more, the Foundation’s geological
tests suggested that the network of tunnels
was almost four whole decades old.
That would have placed the date of their creation
about ten years after the disappearances of
everyone in Darrington.
Naturally, the Foundation immediately launched
a mission to explore more of the tunnels.
Before even completing a full sweep of the
underground space in its entirety, they had
made another discovery.
Contained within the tunnels was over a whole
ton of organic material that had been mostly
preserved without decomposing too much.
The SCP Foundation began gathering samples
for testing, finding most of this material
to be severely desiccated dermis tissue.
That’s the dense layer of skin beneath the
epidermis, and it had all been entirely dried
out.
But that wasn’t all the testing uncovered.
According to genetic analysis, the tissue
had two distinct types of DNA present.
The first being easily identified as human
genetic material, which made sense.
Despite the material lacking in moisture,
the dermis tissue didn’t match the skin
of any other mammal.
But then there was the other DNA present.
Combined with the expected human DNA was the
presence of something else that the Foundation
researchers had quite some difficulty finding
a match for.
Eventually, they determined that this genetic
material entangled with human DNA belonged
to the Cicadtta montana… better known as
the New Forest cicada.
Cicadas again.
Cicada DNA mixed with human DNA, discovered
in a large network of underground tunnels.
All beneath the same town where a pastor had
his congregation crush cicada shells in their
left hands during one of his sermons.
Ten years before the sinkhole incident, the
Foundation was alerted to a particular YouTube
channel by the name of ‘Kai Sanchez: Positively
Rich’.
On the surface, Kai was one of many online
grifters, preaching about how easy it was
to quickly achieve an obscene amount of wealth
by simply believing in yourself.
Usually, if not always, these types of people
were trying to scam their audience of loyal
subscribers into investing in some kind of
illicit moneymaking scheme or any number of
other cons; promising their followers easy
money that never came.
But Kai Sanchez’s channel was slightly different.
So much so that the Foundation had to contain
his entire audience, deeming them to have
been affected by SCP-3089.
The video that caught the Foundation’s attention
was an hour-long upload from Kai titled ‘Seven
Secrets to Ascend the Ladder of Prosperity’.
There was that word again – prosperity – the
same thing Pastor Jenner had promised his
congregation in Darrington.
And the similarities didn’t end there.
In his video, much like the pastor during
his sermons, Kai Sanchez encouraged his audience
to visualize their success in order to achieve
it.
He implied that the human consciousness could
impact reality; for example, if his viewers
just imagined themselves having a bigger bank
account or looking more attractive, then these
things would manifest themselves in the real
world.
One of Kai’s ‘Secrets to Ascend the Ladder
of Prosperity’ was as follows: “Visualize
your ascendance.
Re-imagine yourself as someone who can reach
the top of that ladder.
Shed your old identity.
Tear it off and throw it aside – like dead
skin.
You won't need it.
Not where you're going.”
The resemblance to Pastor Jenner’s sermons
was uncanny.
Kai’s video even encouraged that his audience
leave scraps out to lure stray cats into their
homes, and then, once they had one, to take
a knife and… well, you remember what happened
in Darrington.
But Kai Sanchez made sure to specify: “Remember
to hold the knife with your left hand…”
Another online community was tagged by the
Foundation for similar teachings.
This group of insular men were trying to apply
the same methodology primarily to attract
women.
However, they also reasoned it could be used
to improve their own financial status and
physical stature; all done through visualizing
and believing that doing so would make these
things improve.
That having faith would grant them prosperity.
This disturbed community even tried to use
bug-rattlers to emit frequencies to aid in
attracting women.
Contained within these rattlers were the preserved
remains of… cicadas.
Male cicadas have tymbals, structures on their
outer shell that emit a loud hissing, chittering
noise that they often use to find a mate,
after spending so much time dormant underground…
before burrowing up to the surface.
And if you’ve been paying attention, you
might be able to guess exactly where this
is going…
SCP-3089 is a phenomenon that occurs within
communities of people who are seeking some
form of prosperity.
Whether that community be a town, a group
of like-minded people online, or any other
group of collected individuals.
The particular type of prosperity these people
are all seeking can be anything; from spiritual
enlightenment, to financial success.
The SCP Foundation doesn’t yet quite understand
exactly how SCP-3089 starts, only that communities
affected by it will attempt to achieve their
chosen material success through the application
of rituals, like visualizing what they hope
to overcome and achieve, and practicing sacrifices.
In short, these people have to believe these
acts will grant them what they want.
They need to be willing to go far enough to
do unspeakable things.
They need to have faith.
Although what they don’t realize is, some
things can feed on that faith, they can harvest
it…
Before these communities realize the terrible
things that they have done – or who exactly
has tricked them into performing these rituals
– they’ll begin to undergo a horrific
transformation process; known as SCP-3089-B.
It begins in the chrysalis stage.
Members of a community that has been affected
by SCP-3089 will experience a declined state
of metabolism.
Now classified as instances of SCP-3089-A,
their brain activity, heart rate, and body
temperature will all begin to lower.
Over a period of between three and six hours,
these people will then suffer a change to
their epidermis – the outer layer of skin.
It starts to harden, until it has formed a
dense, brittle substance…
like a shell.
Next comes the second stage of SCP-3089-B:
metamorphosis.
Internally, SCP-3089-A individuals will develop
a number of teratomas – a type of germ cell
tumor that can contain several different types
of tissue, such as hair, muscle, and bone.
During the next two or three weeks, these
tumors will expand and dissolve the person’s
soft tissue.
Then there’s the final stage: emergence.
An instance of SCP-3089-A will exit its dormant
state that began in the initial stage.
Once they have awoken, then… something exits
the outer epidermal shell.
It will not communicate.
Some will retain remnants of internal organs
– such as eyes or lungs – however, these
are vestigial, no longer serving any purpose.
The brain functions deviate from any normal
human patterns.
Having completed the process, this… thing
will attempt to burrow down into the soil
via any means at its disposal.
An outer shell.
Digging into the soil.
The tunnels underneath Darrington.
The genetic material uncovered below.
Dermis tissue with two types of DNA.
A mix of human … and cicada.
There is something out there.
It is preying on people’s faith, their longing
for prosperity.
Then, when these communities are presented
with someone who can take advantage of that
faith – like Pastor Jenner or Kai Sanchez
– they find themselves encouraged to push
their faith to its furthest limit.
And then, they’re rewarded by becoming something
else…
something nightmarish.
The question is: when they wake up, and crawl
back out from their tunnels, leaving a sinkhole
in their wake… where do these cicada creatures
go?
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now go and check out “SCP-3004 INSECT GOD
IMAGO” and “SCP-2852 SADISTIC MADMAN PARTY
CRASHER COUSIN JOHNNY” to uncover more information
about a pair of anomalies with a surprising
connection to That Old Time Religion!